I'm pretty sure you can relate to this
scenario you're in the middle of a
pleasant conversation BAM I feel like
this is becoming an epidemic we're all
basically forming into mindless zombies
who feed off of pictures posts status
updates and then keep refreshing the
same social sites over and over and over
and over and invent is free a few months
ago I was trying to really kick this
habit
so instead reaching for my phone I would
force myself to grab a book and after
that I kind of noticed exactly how much
has reflex that has become in our
society are you driving then you're
probably on your phone are you watching
a movie or watching TV then you are
probably on your phone did you go to the
bathroom recently then you're probably
on your phone you gotta wash your hands
now so I really encourage you know I
challenge you to see how much time you
can spend off of your phone see if you
can even go out of the house without it
and not feel naked but try substituting
something else for your phone and your
computer screens even if it's just for a
little while even if it's just to
reflect on how much time you actually
spend on it because time is the one
thing that we can't replace and I think
it's pretty good to know where it goes
I'll see you next week stay awesome
Gotham oh and thank you so much to
everyone who had a really nice thing to
say on my last video the please don't
kill yourself I've been wanting to talk
about it for a while but obviously I had
my reservations about it but the
response was really wonderful and really
encouraging and thanks yeah thank you